Hello world.
It's the Raj and today I'm introducing a crypto currency for our community
called Saroj coin that will help grow us so we can solve AI faster.
It's designed for programming wizards and will act as the fuel for our global
network to expand to fund AI research,
collaborate with me,
empower each other to spread AI knowledge and ultimately become the school of
Ai.
There is no ICO and this isn't some get rich quick scheme tron coin and as I
explained this,
you'll see exactly what I'm talking about.
I'm going to talk about our history,
where we are now and where we're going.
Then I'm going to explain exactly how I built Saroj coin and how you can help.
And just about two years,
our youtube community has grown to about 270,000 developers coming from over 150
countries globally that speak over 200 languages.
I've since traveled around the world to meet some of you in person.
I started the channel while I was living in San Francisco,
but now I kind of live all over the place.
I've had subscriber meetups in Amsterdam,
London,
New Delhi,
Los Angeles,
and New York City.
So far our community ranges in age from eight years old up to people in their
eighties.
Yes,
eight years old.
I'm serious young wizards like Simon who I recently took the train to meet in
Brussels already has a headstart on his neural network projects
recurrence,
uh,
which is uh,
all that works examples.
That's why it says
current network and I'm making up for grade,
which
was our slack channel is massive with a new wizard joining every two seconds.
And we have active community members on Twitter,
Facebook,
and read it every single day.
Between 500 and 800 wizards join our community on Youtube.
And I've received countless mindblowing coding submissions from our best and
brightest on this channel.
We truly are a global network of developers with a single mission to solve AI
through research and education and use it to benefit humanity.
So how does a crypto currency fit into all of this?
What consider us a network.
Networks are digital organisms.
There a symbiosis of digital and biological intelligence more capable than the
sum of its parts.
Edges between humans in the graph are strengthened by automation.
If incentives are democratized to all nodes,
it can grow an order of a magnitude faster.
I've got an incentive to grow this community by gaining subscribers,
but if I can give you guys that incentive as well,
together we can grow much faster.
Saroj coin is a crypto currency that you can both earn and spend.
In order earn Saroj coin.
You can give a referral link to a friend.
Once you have your own Saroj coin public address,
you can use your referral link,
which will be at Saroj coin.io/your public key.
When you share your referral link and a friend clicks on it,
it will take them to my channel asking them to subscribe.
If they do subscribe,
you earn Suraj coin.
The web app acts as the intermediary between calling the Youtube Api for a new
subscription and the Saroj coin blockchain.
This is an oracle.
The community has the public key of the Oracle and can govern what the Oracle is
allowed to do,
like grant coins.
It's publicly verifiable.
The reason for using an oracle is because blockchain's can't access data outside
their network.
On oracle is a data feed provided by a third party service designed for use in
smart contracts on the blockchain.
Oracle's provide external data and trigger smart contract executions when
predefined conditions meet.
These conditions could be any data like weather,
temperatures,
price fluctuations,
or in our case Youtube subscriptions.
There is also a treasury for our community.
This will be a fund that the community can vote on proposals for and decide
where the funds go.
The funds can be spent on AI research initiatives electing community
representatives who can do things like host hackathons or moderate the slack
channel or even funding other creators that are dedicating their time and
resources to spreading AI knowledge.
No one,
not even me,
can withdraw money from that fund it.
We'll take the consensus of the community to decide how much and if certain
proposals received funds allocated to them.
The more Saroj coins someone owns,
the more voting power they have.
This idea was inspired by the dash and card Dano.
Cryptocurrencies validators in the network receive rewards for validating
transactions.
There are two types of transactions,
taxed and non taxed transactions.
The tax transactions are from a member receiving Saroj coin for referring a new
member and the validator gaining a reward.
15% of the transaction is sent to the fund of the Treasury and 10% is sent to
me.
Send and receive transactions between members are not taxed.
This way.
The treasury grows in value over time and I received Saroj coined that.
I can then give back to the community in novel ways that I think of.
So that's how you can earn through Raj coin,
but what can you spend it on?
Usually there is some scarce resource that gives a currency value and in our
case that scarce resource is me.
You can use Suraj coin to spend it on my attention via hourly meetings and video
collaborations.
It will also unlock access to any merchandise I decide to sell private events.
I host an exclusive content that I could make some time in the future.
So Raj coin is built on tendermint proof of stake.
Consensus tendermint is a blockchain engine that lets you write blockchains in
any language.
The specific framework used is called lotion and it's a javascript framework
built on tendermint,
which makes it easy to create blockchain applications.
It lets you write a scalable blockchain that can easily inter operate with other
blockchains at any moment in time.
The whole state of your blockchain is represented by a single javascript object
called the state.
Users can create transactions.
These are javascript objects that tell the application how to modify the
blockchains state.
Every user who runs a lotion APP will interact with the same blockchain and
anyone can create a transaction and it will automatically find its way to
everyone else running the app and modify their states.
Everyone's states objects.
We'll constantly be kept in sync with each other.
A lotion application is just a single function of signature state transaction
which modifies your blockchain state in response to a transaction.
Both are just objects.
This is made possible by tendermint,
which exists specifically for synchronizing state machines across networks.
The goal of a blockchain is to represent a single state being concurrently
edited in order to avoid conflicts between concurrent edits.
It represents the state as a ledger.
A series of transactions apply to an initial state.
The blockchain must allow all connected nodes to agree about which
transformations are valid and they're ordering within the ledger to accomplish
this.
A blockchain is composed of three protocols,
the network protocol,
the consensus protocol,
and the transaction protocol.
The network protocol is how nodes in the network tell each other about new
transactions,
blocks and other notes.
Usually a pure to pure gossip network.
The consensus protocol is the set of rules that nodes should follow to determine
which particular ordered set of transformations should be in the ledger at a
given moment.
In bitcoin,
the chain with the highest difficulty seeing via node is treated as the highest
truth.
The transaction protocol describes what makes transactions valid and how they
should modify the blockchains state.
When we're writing a lotion APP,
we're only responsible for writing the transaction protocol.
Under the hood.
Tendermint is handling the consensus and network protocols.
When we start our lotion APP,
uh,
tendermint node is also started,
which will handle all of the communication with other nodes running our lotion
app.
There are three points to remember from this video.
So Raj coin is a cryptocurrency for programming wizards that will help grow our
community so we can solve Ai.
It will act as the fuel for our Global Ai Community to expand,
fund AI research,
collaborate with me,
and empower each other to spread AI knowledge.
Ultimately becoming the school of Ai.
You can earn Saroj coin by referring new wizards to the community and eventually
by creating educational content around Ai,
doing AI research or by being elected as a community representative,
you can spend Saroj coin on meeting time with me.
Video collaborations together,
merchandise exclusive content and private events.
And Saroj coin was created using lotion,
a framework for building blockchains in javascript powered by tendermint
consensus.
Everyone who holds Saroj coin will be incentivized to help grow the network.
In addition to needing more subscribers,
I need help creating subtitles for my videos,
for promoting my content on social media,
getting more PR coverage,
moderating the slack channel,
and so many other things I haven't even thought about right now.
The great thing about a cryptocurrency is that it allows for the creation of a
decentralized governance structure.
All of these tasks can be proposed by anyone in the community and we can
collectively fund someone to complete those tasks.
If that person's successfully does the task,
it benefits everyone,
not just me.
Since everyone holds Saroj coin,
this is quite an ambitious experiment and a lot can go wrong,
but if you believe in me,
you believe in this community and you believe in our mission to solve Ai,
believe in Saroj coin.
This week's coding challenge is to contribute to Saroj coin.
Check out the get hub repository for ways that you can contribute and post your
github pull request link in the youtube comments section.
I'll announce the top two entries next week.
If you want to find ways that you can earn Saroj coin right now,
check the video description for some info.
Please subscribe for more programming videos,
and for now,
I've got to work on Suraj Goin so thanks for watching.